the greatest love story ever told Romeo
sweet Juliet was missing a chapter
mine son of a
no get up you lazy cow I have cholera
you do not have cholera you don't
understand they were being all gross and
he was saying things to her that he just
said to me three days ago yes three
nurse
so you're gonna break them up of course
I am Romeo and Juliet doesn't even sound
right you want my help with this we just
need to stop a wedding my boyfriend is
about to make the biggest mistake of his
life hang on a second it's your
boyfriend's wedding
ouch
blow me
Roslyn I met a boy let me guess Romeo
Montague isn't it everybody knows Romeo
Montague but Juliet if I settle down
with just one man when you can sample at
the buffet of Life who wants to buy us
some drinks
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a difference
[Music]
I just wonder if all this drama
adding to the attraction I'm going to
fake my own death I'll drink this potion
it'll look like I'm dead that is quite
possibly the dumbest thing I've ever
heard in my life
you drink it already oh Juliet
[Music]